we are honored to be joined right now by
the president of El Salvador president
Mr President thanks so much for coming
on so it sounds to me like you reduced
the murder rate in El Salvador in a
pretty straightforward way I wonder why
other heads of state aren't calling you
for advice on how to do it in their
countries
thank you Tucker for having me and I got
to be here well I don't know every
country I think have has their own
problems I would guess that probably our
approach that is very very popular with
the people has a problem and and the
problem is that it has common sense
and yes I say it's a problem because
usually the new wave of governance is
taking away common sense and started
doing things the other way around the
way that of course you shouldn't do them
so when used it seems like when you
became president in 2019 you focused
very specifically on crime gangs murder
is that correct and why did you do that
why that issue well not only on crime of
course we focus on other issues
Education Health Public Works investment
tourism infrastructure
Etc but of course crime is the most
important thing I mean you you might
enjoy enjoy a road or a beach but that's
if you're alive so of course the lives
of the people are the most important
thing so that's why we focus on crime
more but of course we did focusing on
all the other issues as well
so you've uh threatened to cut off food
to gang members in prison if they don't
stop the killings on the outside do you
think that they are directing those
killings they're responsible for them
and do you think this will work well at
the beginning they were they were
ordering the killings from the prisons
and the prisons they had if you see most
of the persons Latin America they're
like
um
headquarters for Crime they'll be there
they have phones internet access
computers they will give orders uh from
the answer to the outside it's
now you can find everywhere in in
Central and then in America you can find
all of those examples now in the Sabbath
are communicating to the outside it's
it's impossible you can't communicate
from a person to the other side that's
there's the internet access is blocked
it's impossible so but but still all
these gang members are the bosses of the
other gang members outside so of course
uh gang members outside resent if you uh
and what would like if you do something
to their bosses inside the prisons so we
one of the one of the things we did was
we threatened gang members outside that
we will take retaliation with their
people inside if they continue the
killings of innocent people in El
Salvador that actually if if some people
don't know this video so there was
actually the murder capital of the world
I mean we were a lot more dangerous than
Iraq Afghanistan Syria you name it El
Salvador was the worst uh and the most
dangerous place to live it was the
murder capital of the world and now
we're we're on our way to be the safest
country in the whole American continent
it's an amazing story and I hope mayors
of our cities Baltimore Gary Indiana New
York City will call you for advice on
how to replicate your successes uh Mr
President thank you for joining us
tonight we appreciate it thank you thank
you Tucker hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else